Oh, pauvre bête !
Eh bien, il n’a pas hésité !
Ah je comprends mieux : c’est pas qu’avec
les chiens, mais avec les journalistes aussi
!
Mais bon, s’il faut ça pour devenir président…
bahil le faut !
Je vais vous expliquerpourquoi Frank Underwood,
le personnage principal de la fameusesérie
House of Cards, ira loin.
Vous êtes sur 1000 idées de culture générale,
la chaîne qui parle du meilleur de la pensée
sans vous prendre la tête.
Bonjour, je suis Romain, le créateur du site
1000 idées de culture générale et coauteur
du manuel du même nom.
Je vais vousparler aujourd'hui de ce qu’on
appelle le machiavélisme, c’est-à-dire
la doctrine politique de Machiavel.
Alors,Machiavel c’est un philosophe italien
de la Renaissance qui avait l’ambition de
conseiller les dirigeants.
Il a notamment écrit Le Princepour reprendre
du service auprès des Médicis, qui étaient
alors au pouvoir à Florence. Dans ce livre,
il débarrasse l’action politique des scrupules
du droit et de la morale, ce qui semble aussi
être le cas du protagoniste de la série
House of Cards.
Je vais vous montrer en 3 points pourquoi
Machiavel est le véritable conseiller deFrank
Underwood.
À de nombreuses reprises dans la série,
Frank Underwood se revendique pragmatique
en s’adressant directement au téléspectateur.
Il va même assez loin en défendant le caractère
« impitoyable» de son pragmatisme (en
anglais, ruthless pragmatism).
Le pragmatisme, ça vient dugrec pragma,
qui veut dire « action » ; c’est doncl’attitude
qui consiste à s’adapter à la réalité
par l’action, plutôt que de s’accrocher
à une théorie.
En étant à ce pointpragmatique, Frank
Underwood applique le conseil de Machiavel,
parce que le philosophe prônait un réalisme
extrême.
Ce réalisme se traduit d’abord par unevision
pessimiste de la nature humaine : pour Machiavel,tous
les hommes sont méchants et égoïstes ; ce
sont des tyrans en puissance qu’il faut
soumettre par la force ; ils n’agissent
qu’en fonction de froids calculs d’intérêt.
Ensuite, pour Machiavel, le dirigeant ne doit
pas gouverner en fonction d’idées, mais
simplement chercher à préserver l’équilibre
précaire des intérêts conflictuels sur
lequel repose l’ordre social.
En clair, c’est vain de vouloir changer
les choses, parce qu’on risque de les faire
empirer et de mettre en danger son propre
pouvoir.
Bon, il ne faut pas pour autant prendre Machiavel
pour le chantre de l’immobilisme en politique.
Si vous avez déjàregardé la série, alors
vous savez que la plus grande force de Frank
Underwood c’est de ne pas baisser les bras
devant l’adversité, et de toujours imaginer
de nouvelles solutions pour faire face aux
obstacles.
Cette grande capacité d’adaptation est
cohérente avec le pragmatisme, ç’en est
même une conséquence : être pragmatique,
ça demande de réviser ses hypothèses, voire
tout simplementde les abandonner quand les
effets de l’action ne sont pas ceux escomptés.
Par exemple, quand, au début de la saison
1,Frank Underwood n’est pas nommé vice-président
alors qu’il était très fortement pressenti
pour le poste, il est très rapide à réviser
ses plans pour parvenir à son objectif par
d’autres moyens.
Cette capacité d’adaptation, elle est,
d’après Machiavel, cruciale pour le dirigeant
politique.
Pourquoi ? Parce que le cours des événements
- ce qu’il appelle la fortune -est imprévisible,
et qu’il balaie facilement toutes les hypothèses,tous
les projets, et toutes les espérances.
En politique, en particulier, on regarde l’histoire
et on a l’impression que le futur sera à
l’image du passé ; mais il y a en réalité
une très grande irrégularité des phénomènesqui
demande au prince de s’adapter en permanence.
À tel point que l’enjeu crucialdu dirigeant
politique, c’est pour Machiavel de faire
correspondre son projet à l’esprit du temps,
plutôt que de prétendreinutilement forcer
le cours des choses.
C’est encore une conséquence du pragmatisme
prône par Machiavel :peu importent les
idées, seules comptent les circonstances
; il faut savoir ressentir l’esprit du temps,
etsaisir les opportunités qu’il offre.
Cette capacité d’adaptation du dirigeant,
Machiavel l'appelle la virtu…
...à ne vraimentpas confondre avec la vertu
morale !
C’est ce qui choque dans l’action de Frank
Underwood : il a totalement évacué les questions
morales.
Remarquez bien que je ne parle pas d’immoralisme,
car la différence est importante.
L’idée ça n’est pas queFrank Underwood
cherche à faire ce qui est contraire à la
morale, ; c’est qu'il ne prend pas du tout
en compte la morale comme critère de son
action.
Si des moyens conventionnels luisuffisent
pour arriver à sa fin, eh bien, pas de problème,il
les emploie.
Mais s’il faut employer des moyens extrêmes
; s’il faut mentir, manipuler, trahir,tuer,
eh bien il le fait sans hésitation,de sang
froid.
Le machiavélisme, c’est doncêtre prêt
à tout pour parvenir à sa fin, car la fin
justifie les moyens.
Machiavel recommande au dirigeant d’inspirer
la crainte, de mentir,de manipuler, de corrompre
et de ne pas hésiter à faire des boucs émissaires.
Il écrit même qu’ilest nécessaire,
pour gérer l’État,d’« agir contre
sa parole, contre la charité, contre l’humanité,
contre la religion ».
Machiavel encourage le gouvernant à violer
la morale et le droit autant que nécessaire,
mais il le prévient qu’il est très important
de garder une façade morale.
En conclusion, Frank Underwood ira loin parce
qu’il est machiavélique, c’est-à-dire
qu’il est pragmatique, opportuniste et qu’il
est prêt à tout pour parvenir à ses fins.
Et d’ailleurs, il va très loin dans la
série !
Même si je trouve qu’on a vraiment l’impression
que Machiavel est le conseiller du personnage
de House of Cards, il y a quand même quelques
petites limites à cette idée.
Tout d’abord, chezMachiavel, le dirigeant
a une certaine responsabilité à l’égard
de la société, alors que Frank Underwood
paraît rouler pour lui seul exclusivement.
Ensuite, le personnage semble prendre unplaisir
sadiqueà mentir, tromper, et manipuler,
alors que Machiavel présente simplementces
extrémités comme des nécessités dont l’accomplissement
demande même un certain courage.
Enfin, Frank Underwood va si loin dans le
viol de la morale et du droit qu’il devient
très compliqué de conserver une façade
crédible.
Or, Machiavel nousaprévenus : il faut
à tout prix sauver les apparences !
Si vous avez aimé la vidéo, mettez un pouce
bleu et abonnez-vous à la chaîne pour être
prévenu de la sortie de la suivante.
Pour lire ma synthèse du machiavélisme de
Machiavel sur le site1000 idées de culture
générale, voire pour pourlire l'ouvrageLe
Princedirectement, les liens sontdans
la description.
N’hésitez pas non plus à laisserdes
commentaires.
Pour recevoir les dernières idées de culture
générale synthétisées dans le format le
plus clair possible,vous pouvez vous inscrire
à la newsletter en laissant votre adresse
e-mail sur le site.
Je suis Romain et sous étiez sur 1000 idées
de culture générale.
Rappelez-vousvous n’avez pas besoin de
vous prendre la tête pour vous intéresser
au meilleur de la pensée.